(applauding)
(dramatic music)
(audience laughing)
Hi.
Oh, yeah.
There ya go.
(audience laughs)
Conan Obrien.
It's O'Brien, Conan O'Brien.
I'm him!
The comedian.
TV host.
Doing a big show in Mexico City.
Check it out.
(audience laughing)
Would you please step out of line, sir?
Uh, okay.
We have a new policy.
Americans are subject to extreme vetting.
Extreme vetting?
You might just be one of those bad hombres.
(audience laughing)
Okay, look, I see what you're doing, alright.
We got some new people running the United States,
and that's created some tension between our countries.
But you can't lump all Americans into one group.
It's not fair.
It's stereotyping.
(laughing)
Gracias, thank you so much.
I'll...
(dog growls)
That's just my-
(dramatic music)
Okay, that's my favorite sunscreen.
It's really good.
I wasn't sure if you guys would have good Mexican food.
(audience laughing)
(audience boos loudly)
I stayed there like 15 years ago, okay?
And I stole the towel.
(dog growling)
That is yours to keep,
and I'll just see myself through the border.
This is a great, great gate.
(dog barks)
(upbeat music)